so it's Tuesday morning of the second
week of the UN conference on climate
change and Here I am in the media center
finally after a grueling ordeal
yesterday I spent nine hours getting
accreditation yesterday and that's
absolutely crazy because I had pre
registered for the conference as heard
all of the other delegates who are here
yesterday what happened was well I
suppose you could only really describe
it as a complete organizational break
down hundreds of people we left standing
outside freezing in the cold waiting to
see if they would be allowed to register
for the conference arrived at about
eight-thirty yesterday morning and I
didn't actually get into the building
until half four and i think it took me
probably a couple of hours after that to
actually make it through the
registration process now apparently what
happened was the UN gave accreditation
to over 45,000 people to attend called
15 and the bella center reportedly can
only actually handle 15,000 people at
any one time I had Cidre journalists
from the BBC World Service CNN New
Scientist nature also lots of delegates
but mostly were representatives of NGOs
and that was really the crux of the
problem more than 15,000 representatives
of NGOs registered for this conference
and yesterday the yesterday the UN
decided to clamp down on this they
basically said okay we just can't let
that many NGOs in so allegedly they're
going to restrict the number of NGO
representatives to a thousand by
Thursday and 290 on Friday which is
causing outrage among the people who've
come far and wide to be here so when I
finally got in yesterday at four-thirty
many of these people were still left
outside waiting in the cold
I'm here representing Colorado State
University we are coordinating a project
for the global environment facility
which is looking at producing a system
for sustainable land management projects
to estimate their carbon benefits I came
here at nine o'clock and queued for four
hours I got cold and had to leave and
now come back again to try to queue to
get in again my name is Dave Blakeney
I'm a national representative with the
Canadian union of postal workers and I'm
here for two reasons personally I have a
13 year old daughter and I want her to
have a better earth than the one that
exists now and organizationally we're
here to make amends with the global
South because we know the north is
basically its wealth and it's big cities
and everything have been built on the
backs of indigenous people and
colonization and we have a historic that
and speaking of that I mean it's really
remarkable the line of the queue here
today when waiting for hours and hours
and hours and it seems to me if this
were a shopping mall we would be right
through with this were a rock concert
we'd be right through but when it comes
for the climate it seems that human
beings still aren't the priority I'm not
sure whether those two people managed to
get in yesterday and I'm sure that many
of the people who were in the queue with
me didn't a lot of the frustration came
from the fact that there was no rhyme or
reason to who they were letting in or
why they were letting people in so
apparently they have their act sorta
today and at least press are being
fast-tracked through the system and I'm
off now to Eun press conference to find
out what's happening on the negotiations
from a verge of war but keep checking
our blog climate feedback for updates
I've just returned from the UN press
conference where one of the reporters
asked UN officials about the ruckus
outside yesterday surprisingly UN
climate chief eva gabor to personal
responsibility for the incident I think
part of the problem for 15 years that
you can't fit size 12 feet in two sizes
shoes we have a conference center which
fire safety reasons can accommodate
15,000 and we have 46 thousands I want
to be here to begin this to witness it
and after their voice and that is
physically impossible and unsafe I
supposedly could have stopped the
registration when we reach the 15,000
won that are thinking while people come
and people go out people come to the
first week you can come from second week
so let's make sure that we register as
many as possible but but we can't
guarantee that everyone will be able to
get into the building what they want to
get is that would be unsafe I think the
people are spending it in appropriate
amount of time queuing outside I think
that that is very bad possible in
summary two boys defense of the incident
was that the UN decided not to cap
delegates are 15 pairs and on the basis
that not all people would want to attend
all of the conference it seems they may
have been wrong on that one
myself enough rope there to do it at the
beginning of the press conference UN
climate chief event of war walked in
carrying a life ring saying act now save
lives presumably the implication was
that ministers will need to be extremely
focused in the next two to three days if
Copenhagen is to see a strong political
deal
you